you can't become attached to the outcome  publishing is a weird business it's more  of a hobby and it has all these signals  in it that don't make sense great books  don't sell that well lousy books sell a  lot of copies good people spend their  lives promoting books that's not what  you need to do my zazimov who I used to  work with he was one of the most  successful science fiction authors ever  and I'm sitting in his apartment near  Lincoln Center in New York and I said so  Isaac you've written some of the most  important books of all time and you've  done 400 books how did you do that he  walks me over to this little tiny table  with a manual typewriter right he says  what I do is I wake up in the morning  and I walk over to this typewriter and I  type from 6 30 to noon every day it  doesn't matter if it's good I just have  to type but we're not gonna get attached  to whether it's a bestseller we're going  to get focused on did this book be what  I wanted